[Music]
good morning everybody vladimir putin
may have said he's moving russian troops
into two breakaway regions of ukraine to
perform peacekeeping roles but as far as
the west is concerned it's a sign of an
imminent invasion within the last few
hours military vehicles including tanks
have been seen on the outskirts of
donetsk the capital of one of the
breakaway regions of eastern ukraine in
an address on state tv in moscow last
night president putin announced that he
was recognizing the breakaway regions as
independent states
our security and defense editor deborah
haynes joining us now live from the
ukrainian capital of kiev um hello to
you uh deborah good morning um is this
be how is this being viewed in ukraine
today
with fear and concern events yesterday
unfolded so quickly you'll remember it
started with hopes of of diplomacy led
by france's president and ended like you
said with tanks rolling into separatist
held parts of ukraine after the russian
president having convened the national
security council which was broadcast on
television this incredible theater
deciding that he was going to recognize
these two breakaway regions that have
been under the control of russia-backed
separatists for the past eight years
effectively shredding eight years of
diplomatic efforts to try to resolve
this crisis through negotiation turning
his back on what's known as the minsk
accords and putting his troops into that
territory saying that they're there as
peacekeepers and building on this false
narrative that has been generated over
the past few days in particular that the
ukrainian government poses a threat to
civilians living in that area that's
simply not true say the ukrainian
government but despite that we saw those
images didn't we of civilians being
evacuated out of the separatist held
parts of luhansk and donetsk over the
last few days and now these russian
forces supposedly peacekeepers moving in
all of this watched on in horror by the
rest of the country and the big concern
being that should russia accuse ukraine
of launching shells against its troops
in that area even if that's not true
then that could be the trigger for a
wide scale invasion
okay thank you thanks very much i know
you're going to update us throughout the
course of the morning thank you as you
can see um the health secretaries where
there's lots to talk to you about this
morning let's start good morning i
wonder we could start with ukraine um
is this the de facto invasion we're
waking up to a very dark day in europe
and uh it's clear from what we've
already
seen and and found out today that
the russians president putin has decided
uh to to
attack the sovereignty of
ukraine and his territorial integrity
we've always said that's completely
unacceptable we've seen that he has
recognized these breakaway eastern
regions in ukraine
and from the reports or i think we can
already tell that he's sent in tanks and
troops and so i think it's
from that you can conclude that the
invasion of ukraine has begun what are
we going to do about it
there's a cobra meeting taking place
right now chaired by the prime minister
and
of course that will be discussing what
action we will take we have been very
clear right from the start of this
crisis that we wouldn't hesitate to take
action i understand the prime minister
uh spoke to president zielinski of
ukraine last night assured him of our
support but also that we will be
introducing sanctions as we said we
always will
what sort of military support can we
offer
we've already been providing military
support to ukraine now for a number of
months and and certainly that's picked
up in the last few weeks
i'm sure that will be part of the
discussion uh at the cobra meeting and
we will continue to provide such support
but also look at how we can
take action against russia uh through
sanctions and and there are measures
that that can be taken because of
legislation that we had introduced last
year that will help in responding and
responding uh very quickly and i'm sure
that we make those sanctions targeted as
possible to the people that are
responsible for this fragrant violation
of international law i got the
impression that there were sort of two
tiers of economic sanctions why are we
are we still going to do that and
or are we just going to hit him hard
well
i think i'd want to wait for the outcome
of the cobra meeting i think that is
that is appropriate and i know the after
that meeting is concluded the prime
minister will make a statement to
parliament and set out what we know
about the current situation on the
ground but also what action we will take
the weaponry at the moment is defensive
are we going to send offensive weaponry
again i think that these will be exactly
the things that are rightly discussed in
the cobra meeting where the ministers at
that meeting will be presented with all
the latest information intelligence
including uh from our allies across nato
and once that
meeting has concluded i think it is
right that the prime minister sets out
the action to parliament first just
another question on that then we'll move
on to covid if i may what should brits
do that are in these two breakaway
regions at the moment well we've already
advised uh british citizens uh to to
leave ukraine and and i hope that all
british citizens have been following
that advice of course not everyone uh
does my understanding is that there are
still commercial flights available
people are still able to leave ukraine
and we would continue to advise those
individuals british citizens to leave
ukraine so get out if you can yes
um and just a final thought on that if i
may there was a statement uh overnight
from the white house talking about
basically a communique between the
united states and france and germany and
a couple of times referring to those
three nations why are we not included in
that
well i haven't seen the particular
communique that you refer to but you can
see i think everyone it's been evident
over the last few weeks how important a
role the uk has played
in in this crisis working with our
allies across nato uh in the
conversations the prime minister himself
has been having with
the presidents and leaders of uh
different countries within nato and also
what the prime minister had to say
himself for the recent munich conference
something that will very much be
troubling my viewers this morning i know
you'll want to clear up all restrictions
dropped as far as covert is concerned
from thursday how are we going to future
proof against variants so yesterday it
was was a historic day we were already
the freest country
in europe and yesterday we were able to
go further thanks to the protections
we've built but also the efforts of the
british people and i think it's worth
remembering that the the restrictions
that we had introduced of course they
had an important purpose but they were
never intended to become a way of life
you know they also came at a huge cost
to our freedoms education mental health
and
other significant costs so
you being able to remove them in the way
that we did yesterday was a significant
you know
step forward uh but of course we do need
to remain vigilant so that means we keep
a hold of our primary defenses
especially uh vaccines if we look at the
last few months i think the one thing we
had to take just one thing that made the
biggest difference of all was our
booster program we were the first
country in europe to to be able to boost
50 of our adult population now it's over
70 percent and that's also by the way
one of the reasons i accepted the advice
of the jcvi yesterday to offer a second
booster in the spring
to those aged over 75 elderly people in
care homes
in in september over 50s is that right
well there
may be i mean what the jcbi said
yesterday that is their current view but
of course they will keep that under
review but there may well be i think
it's likely there will be one in the
winter but we it's we can't set this
point for what age group that will be in
again we will listen to the jcbi at that
time but certainly for the spring there
will be one for the group of people that
the jcpi set out in terms of your
particular question though about um
future yeah
yeah yeah
and that's and and that is it is right
we have to understand that clearly your
covert is still out there we may be done
with kobe but it's certainly not done
with us and we have to remain cautious
and vigilant and that is why we set out
yesterday also just how we will continue
to do that so vaccines remain an
important part of our defenses the
antivirals and other treatments that we
have also
will play a continued important role but
also we've put in place a surveillance
system you know that we're able to
detect any potential future threats and
also the ability for us to react quickly
should that happen great way to do that
would be to keep lateral flow tests
you're not going to do that and we
understand that it's going to cost
something like 2 billion pounds a month
seems like an awful lot of money um
should we have free covid tests lateral
flow tests for some groups uh we will be
keeping free labor tests for some groups
for the most vulnerable so so for
example i mentioned a moment ago we have
antivirals so these are fantastic new
drugs specifically designed for covid
they played a huge role over omicron and
they will continue to play an important
role so for people that are eligible for
those drugs we've targeted those at the
what we call the clinically extremely
vulnerable as defined by the nhs it's
about it's about 1.3 million
people and for them
with its pcrs or any other testing that
we require to to make sure that we know
when
we need to offer those drugs to protect
them those we have testing in place we
will have lateral flow tests
for staff in
for the time being we will keep for
staff in care homes and we know when we
will we will keep it under review so
that is the
the decision we announced yesterday for
certain vulnerable settings essentially
your care homes and hospitals uh lateral
flow tests and pcr tests in some cases
will continue to be used but to all
intents and purposes people won't know
if they've got coveted or not will they
from the first of april
um they won't they won't without a test
of course you won't know and but that
this is you could go to work with covert
well
you
you could go to work with flu and when
we and the reason i say that is that
you know one of the things that the
prime minister rightly said yesterday is
we've got to learn to live with covid as
we have learned to live with other
respiratory diseases you know if someone
thinks that they might have flu
they don't need to take a test you know
you just you recognize the symptoms and
ideally you would you stay away from
work you don't want to infect your
colleagues or friends and and that is
how we have lived with viruses and now
with with covid obviously we couldn't
have done anything like that at the
start of code for and throughout most of
the pandemic because we didn't have the
tools that we have today but the
situation today is very different yeah
but the prime minister did say that we
need to have the german attitude to
calling in sick which basically is if
you're on well you should call in sick
the germans um
they apparently sick pay is 50
pay for 84 weeks ours is 96 pounds 35
pence you can see why people go to work
even when you're feeling unwell we have
a strategy we look at that again look we
you're referring to our statutory sick
pay levels you know fairly
most businesses you know most employers
pay a lot more than that i mean that is
a minimum
you're right that's why i said i
recognize that and that's why i said
most i didn't say yeah but it does and
work is in a very difficult way
it is important to keep your levels of
statutory sick pay and other
benefits uh to keep that uh under review
and that is done at all times but it is
also right that we start moving back to
normal and and and i think this is a
moment you know what the government
announced yesterday it's a moment that
we can all be proud of because we've all
you know we've played a collective
effort uh to to reach this point but
there are sides to it that's my point so
if you are at work and you and a
colleague test positive or you feel that
they have got covered is it reasonable
for you to tell your boss that you're
going to go home
is it i think if you yes i think if you
if you feel that you've got covered and
just as if you feel you've got flu or
some other
virus that you shouldn't really be at
work of course it's reasonable to say to
your boss that
it might not be sensible those employers
who think that that's a bad idea who
wouldn't support that you're saying
actually you need to bear in mind how
your workers might feel yes what we will
be setting out is is guidance your
public health guidance so for now whilst
we're removing the legal requirement to
self-isolate from thursday
that there will be guidance that would
advise you to continue to do so until
the end of march and from the 1st of
april we will set out new guidance that
will be much more general but still
sensible guidance about how you might
behave if you believe that you have some
kind of respiratory or other disease
okay two acronym questions before i let
you go uh these passenger locator forms
bane of travelers lives given um that
you don't have to self-isolate from
thursday if you do have kobe are we
going to get rid of them um well i
wouldn't go quite as far right now and
say we'll get rid of them right away but
i do think now with the measures that
we've announced yesterday uh there is a
case to review them and that review is
being done right now with the transport
secretary in the home office and i'm
sure some progress will be made and um
fixed penalty notices um
are you with the james cleverley school
of thinking which is doesn't matter if
the prime minister has broken the law or
not he should continue on look i'm not
gonna get into this we've discussed this
so many times okay and i think but you
never answered and and and the reason is
that there are authorities official
authorities that are looking into
into this whole issue rightly so
and the prime minister himself has come
to parliament and apologized and set out
what's happening but also he's rightly
not getting involved in what the
authority is doing let's let we should
we'll let the authorities do their work
i don't think it's appropriate to get
into if he's misled parliament should he
resign
well it's
as i said before these are you when you
ask me questions with if and if this
these are hypothetical questions i know
you defined hypothetical for me before
yes i did but that doesn't
so
i've taken that away um but uh i'm not
gonna uh get into this this is the the
you
focus on what's actually with regard to
this the primary says come to parliament
authorities investigating this but i'm
focused on my day-to-day job good to
talk to you as always thank you very
much for joining us thank you and the
ukraine crisis is dominating the front
pages as you can imagine uh this morning
let's start with the guardian russia on
a collision course with west over
ukraine writes the guardian as the uk is
set to respond with tough sanctions the
ft reports president vladimir putin is
poised to recognize eastern ukraine's
two breakaway regions by redrawing
borders
the daily telegraph has president putin
warning of bloodshed and reports russian
forces are being sent into ukraine to
keep the peace in breakaway areas
still to come on the programme for you
discussing the lifting of covid
restrictions in england with professor
paul moss from the institute of
immunology and immunotherapy at the
university of birmingham
discussing the crisis in ukraine with
the defence select committee chair and
former defence minister tobias elwood
and we'll get labour's take on the
ukraine crisis with the shadow defense
secretary john healey
[Music]
the uk's ambassador to the u.n has urged
russia to step back from invading
ukraine after vladimir putin ordered the
deployment of troops to two breakaway
regions in eastern ukraine here's boris
johnson chairing a
cobra meeting to discuss new sanctions
on russia here's our us correspondent
martha kelner
late night in new york and a group of
diplomats making a last-ditch effort to
avert a disaster unfolding 5 000 miles
away mr president it's with great
concern and sadness that i briefed the
council this evening
this emergency meeting was convened
after russian president vladimir putin
ordered his troops into two separatist
pro-moscow regions in eastern ukraine
he calls them peacekeepers
this is nonsense
we know what they really are
in doing so he has put before the world
a choice
we must meet the moment and we must not
look away
and a plea from the british
representative
russia has brought us to the brink
we urge russia to step back
the u.s say they're now convinced that
vladimir putin is intent on war that
these troops are being primed for
conflict but russia's representative at
the un again denying his country is the
aggressor i would like to call upon our
western colleagues to think twice to set
emotions to one side and not to make the
situation worse no one other than you
can hold back the militaristic plans of
kiev and force it to stop the shelling
and provocations against the lugansk and
people's republics these ukrainian
soldiers are staring down the barrel of
a conflict which would devastate their
country as their president called for
calm
we don't owe anything to anyone we won't
give away anything to anyone we are
confident in this
president biden told president zielenski
he remained committed to ukraine's
sovereignty signing an order prohibiting
u.s investment in the two regions of
ukraine which russia is now recognizing
as independent
states
the u.s says more sanctions will be
announced today but as columns of
military vehicles roll towards donyesk
the fear is the time for deterrence and
diplomacy may now be running out martha
kellner sky news washington
tamara is in dining street for us um
hello to you tomorrow
stark words there from the health
secretary saying he concludes that the
invasion of ukraine has begun
yes absolutely the british government is
calling this an invasion the russian
troops moving into those areas of
eastern ukraine last night and that
means once boris johnson has had this
cobra meeting which will discuss what
the actual situation is in eastern
ukraine what the british government is
going to do about it we expect an
immediate action which will be sanctions
boris johnson had already talked about
the moment a russian toe cap crosses
that border there would be sanctions and
we expect them to be set out to
parliament this afternoon and debated
and agreed on
then they will be very much broader than
they have been previously against
russian individuals and companies not
just involved in ukraine but in a range
of different economic sectors and
there's also the prospect of working
with the us and eu to bring in even
tougher sanctions if this escalates
boris johnson also spoke to the
ukrainian president last night vladimir
zelinski and said to him that the uk
expects a full-scale
invasion clearly we're at that stage now
and that in that case the prospect is
that more defensive weaponry will be
sent to him uh in ukraine so we may get
an update on that from this cobra
meeting shortly okay thank you
well let's head to brussels as well
should we laura bonduck is standing by
for us now uh british government
concludes the invasion of ukraine has
begun what's the view where you are this
morning good morning
hi kay well yesterday of course here in
europe it was all about summits now the
talk is all about sanctions we've had a
joint statement from the presidents of
the european commission the european
council they said they condemned the
strongest possible terms the russian
president's decision they said it's a
blatant violation of international law
as well as the minx agreements and the
year they said that the union will react
with sanctions against those involved in
this illegal act the european council
president also tweeted this morning he
had spoken to the ukrainian president to
express the eu's solidarity with him at
this time the question now is what
happens next there was a big meeting
here in brussels yesterday of european
foreign ministers they agreed
that there would be this prepared
package of sanctions
which will be put on the table to be
discussed and i think the level of
sanctions will depend on putin's next
move possible sanctions though would
include the blocking of imported gas and
oil from russia big questions for
germany about the nordstrom 2 gas
pipeline that runs from russia to
germany
possibly the freezing of assets of
individuals as well as companies with
links to moscow
and impossibly the blocking of uh vital
key electrical components all of this is
still to be deconfirmed still to be
discussed but very much the message
coming out of brussel is a united front
and i think europe very much realizes
that putin's move threatens the entire
security of their countries at the
moment
okay thank you thanks a lot
also this morning there are concerns
that the scrapping of free covered tests
at the start of april will adversely
affect the most vulnerable let's speak
should we to maddie who is at a pharmacy
which carries out tests in centre albans
in hertfordshire opens shortly i'm
guessing good morning maddie that
they're going to be pretty busy handing
out those tests while they can
good morning kay yes with the uh
announcement last night that free
testing is ending there will be
presumably a rush the government is
actually acting to stop stop piling to
stop the stockpiling of tests by
limiting the number of um free tests you
can order to once every three days
rather than once every 24 hours but it
shows how worried so many people are
that they will no longer be able to get
free tests whether they have or don't
have symptoms and the government points
to the the huge cost 2 billion pounds a
month to run our current testing program
and says the nhs now has to foot that
bill there won't be new funds for it
which is why it will be limited only the
very elderly and the most vulnerable
will be eligible for free tests the rest
of us will have to pay just like we do
if we're getting a test to go overseas
and the government thinks it will be a
private market like that about 20 pounds
for seven tests but it has been widely
criticized by both patient groups who
say that the very vulnerable the
immunosuppressed have been abandoned by
this policy but also doctors who have
asked
why if the government is is keen to
monitor the spread they are getting rid
of vaccine getting rid of free tests so
we will hope to hear some more answers
from the pharmacy later about what role
they think they can play
lovely thank you maddie thank you
two severe weather warnings have been
issued along the river seven in
worcestershire and shropshire as the
environment agency warns that residents
should prepare for significant flooding
following heavy rainfall from storm
franklin
latest on that with emma she was in
leicester for us yesterday talking about
something completely different she's in
bewdley in worcestershire today totally
versatile what's it looking like where
you are this morning good morning
yeah
hello good morning yes it's already
looking pretty bad here i have to say
i'm just going to step out of the way
and you can have a look um at the river
seven and just how fast it's moving now
the very latest on when the water level
is expected to reach its peak uh says
half past eleven tomorrow morning
actually and on the other side of the
river are vertical barriers on this side
are the temporary um blue barriers
they're at a kind of a diagonal and
actually
they clearly haven't quite done their
trick because
there is water all the way across the
road here all the way up to people's
properties if you have a look at this
direction you can see just
how much this road is already flooded
here so a severe flood warning means
that people are urged to act now
um there is a risk to life a danger to
life and that is the case here in
bewdley but also about 20 miles further
north along the river 7
in ironbridge where they they're
expecting flooding there too
so this a very very worrying time and
just to say i've just spoken to a
neighbor who was hanging out of the
window of their flats
and they said this is the third year
running that this has happened it's
something they are having to get used to
lovely thanks very much thanks a lot i
want to show you this if you're a
numbers nerd cherished today because
it's um a mathematical rarity and i'll
tell you why
it's the 22nd of the second
2022. that's known as a palindrome which
is something that reads the same way
forwards
as it does backwards but not just that
jerry my camera operator is smiling at
this i've got more for you it's also an
ambigum
and it's a mirror day which means it
reads the same
upside down as it does the other way
around
how clever is that amy the director's
just saying we should have made it flip
around well that's your job for the next
hour isn't it it won't appear again in
our lifetime so it's now
or never amy time for a quick look at
the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
that's blown your minds this morning
hasn't it no it's going to stay
unsettled with rain and strong winds
pushing through today leaving sunshine
and showers
fairly mild now with a stiff wind
bringing heavy rain and showers but the
southeast is dry
for now
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
let's start with this should we uh in
the times this morning city hedgehogs
are faring better than their country
cousins as numbers are no longer on the
decline in urban areas the success is
attributed to people creating hedgehog
highways by connecting that's a great
image isn't it uh connecting gardens so
they can travel to find food
and a mate so there you go there you go
it's pausing for a little drink
lovely
adele and her boyfriend getting cozy
courtside at an nba all-star basketball
game in ohio on sunday she looks happy
doesn't she according to the express the
rumor is they're planning to tie the
knot but the ring that sparked the
murmurings earlier this month was
nowhere to be seen as the singer keeps
people guessing
looks very happy indeed
ditch the coat though love not sure
about the coat and in the telegraph
diver alice edgar had a close encounter
with a whale shark in the maldives look
at him her husband took the photo
thankfully the whale shark was just out
grabbing a spot of breakfast and she
wasn't it which is reassuring
well there's been a mixed response to
the decision to lift england's remaining
coveted restrictions this week and end
retesting from april joining us now is
professor paul moss from the institute
of immunology and immunotherapy at the
university of birmingham thank you very
much indeed for joining us
on the program this morning um i don't
know if you managed to hear what the
health secretary was saying to us a
little bit earlier on professor um he
thinks it's the right time do you
well i think okay you have to look at
some of the facts on this this was based
on i think first is the scientific basis
i pick out two things one is the
epidemiology we're seeing cases although
high falling
what's encouraging of course is the
hospitalization and deaths are markedly
down now i think there are 15
associated deaths yesterday so that's
encouraging and then if you associate
that with the immunity that we have in
the population now through vaccination
and of course natural immunity those are
encouraging features
and i think we probably do have to
consider secondly the cost as your
correspondent mentioned
testing at the current level costs
around 15 billion pounds a year i think
that's about 40 million pounds a day we
know that's not sustainable and so the
question is how and when that ends so
that's the basis for it and um i think
some of the things we saw yesterday were
quite reasonable and i like the quite
targeted approach going forward
and as far as the free tests are
concerned they will be available for
some people um for some time
and there will be some inoculations for
some people and could be other people in
september but all of this
assumes that we won't have another
killer version of the virus
absolutely right and i think one thing i
think we can be reassured about is that
um we do have things in place to
look after as best we can some of the
most vulnerable people and also plan for
the future so yes you mentioned vaccines
so we're going to get a fourth vaccine
for people over 75. it's it's a little
bit arbitrary but you know i think
that's probably as good as you can say
at the moment and the immune suppressed
will get their fifth vaccine probably in
the spring
um the testing will carry on as you say
for the most vulnerable they've not been
defined yet but you can imagine that'll
be the most immune suppressed and the
very elderly perhaps over 80. so i think
we do need to see free testing there
and there will be some surveillance of
course carrying on as patrick valen said
yesterday it's likely that we'll get new
viral variants
they may not be quite as relatively mild
as omicron so we have to keep that in
place
do we need annual vaccinations do you
think for for the whole population
it seems that's a default thing that
we're coming to doesn't it we we have
our influenza vaccine once a year and so
people are assuming that we will have a
covert vaccine once you i don't honestly
think um okay that that evidence is
there and we need to monitor that
there's two ways we can do that one is
by assessing the number of infections
that people are getting after
vaccination and seeing if there's
breakthrough and secondly doing studies
on how our immune system is holding up
after vaccination it looks like that
will be the default but of course the
evidence isn't quite there for an annual
vaccination yes okay it's good to talk
to you thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you let's bring in andy
jones should we he's the owner of jones
and sons restaurant in east london hello
g thanks for joining us on the programme
this morning how have you been impacted
how's the business been impacted by um
covert
uh well over the past few years as you
know it's been uh relatively devastating
but we'll bring it kind of into the more
recent times
a couple of weeks before christmas where
we suffered all the cancellations it was
widespread in the media how many
hospitality places restaurants pubs bars
had a wave cancellations the kind of two
weeks before christmas which are really
critical weeks in this industry
since then
it feels like customers have had enough
it feels like customers made a decision
to come back after kind of that wave of
omicron's spread through london
i think a lot of people got the virus
and then
you know decided that it was a cold a
bit like a flu they got over it in a
couple of days and was like okay let's
just get back to normal life
a lot of the restrictions in the
restaurant industry just didn't make
sense to me anyway wearing a mask when
you walk in
then taking off when you sit down
it just felt that it was a bit all over
the place and people have just said
right common sense needs to prevail
let's move forward let's get back into
hospitality let's get going out again
and start socializing
and as far as your customers are
concerned what are you going to are you
still going to ask them for a covered
pass are you going to ask them to wear
masks what have you decided to do
absolutely not i've never asked for kobe
pass passes i've never asked them to
wear masks i've always said it's
pro-choice if you want to wear a mask in
this establishment you're absolutely
welcome too if you don't want to you
don't have to i feel like we're getting
to a situation now where we're being
told we need to be happy to have our
freedoms back now we live in a democracy
i think people should have been able to
make their choices a little while ago
when we came out the really bad phase
that was what six eight months ago this
has been a disaster for business it's
been a disaster financially for the
government i think the reputation of the
government has taken a huge hit as well
and the quicker we can get back to
normal the quicker we can live with this
like they said yesterday i think it's a
good thing for everybody
good to talk to you um good luck going
forward thank you andy
joining us now is lorna fillingham who
is a full-time carer for her 11-year-old
daughter it's good to talk to you on the
program this morning um emily may of
course your little girl um how are you
feeling about the restrictions being
lifted
i'm absolutely astounded by the timing
of this because uh disabled clinically
extremely vulnerable children aged 5-11
were only offered a vaccine about 5-11
days ago and they were offered that
vaccine
because they were considered at more
serious risk of serious effects of povid
now trying to get an appointment for
even the first vaccine caused me no end
of problem and my child will not be
fully vaccinated until eight weeks later
so i
i understand at some point there needs
to be some freedom but these children my
daughter um qualifies because she's
profoundly multiple learning
disabilities but there's other children
on that list who have um some children
with asthma some children with diabetes
and these children are soon going to be
sat in a classroom where they could be
sat absolutely next to somebody
who is has own full-blown coping
who doesn't even know they've got
covered because they're not unable to
get a test so i i absolutely i do
understand that at some point freedom
needs to come i i cannot understand the
reasoning behind why they would put
these vulnerable children at risk at
this time
um we are being told that it
where we are now we should um
compare um covid to the flu do you think
that's a reasonable comparison
um no i don't believe it is there's
people there with long copied and
they're
still very young children being
hospitalized um with with covid so this
has not gone away and at the minute
we're being thrown to the walls because
we
people are going to have the testing
taken away capabilities for testing
taken away there's still an awful lot of
children out there who are uh
in school who will soon be next to a
child
with covid who are still vulnerable and
not fully vaccinated
it's good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed i hope how is the little one
is she okay
she's absolutely fine she's asleep at
the
minute
oh good for her good for her me too
it's good to talk to you thank you very
much thank you
you know it's really difficult isn't it
for all sorts of people and given that
the government is ruling uh changing the
rules from uh thursday and and no free
covet tests at national closure on the
1st of april is what we believe let's uh
lift your mood should we look at this an
iconic stone monument from easter island
began its journey back home yesterday
following a campaign to get it returned
after being housed in a museum in
santiago for
150
years the huge maori statue which weighs
an enormous 715 kilos bit like me after
christmas is being transported to the
chilean city of valparaiso from where it
will set sail on a journey of about five
days to reach the remote easter island
known locally as rapper nui
the initiative is part of a repatriation
programme seeking to return ancestral
artifacts
and it's on its way home after 150 years
they look very pleased about it don't
they
well again returning to the crisis in
ukraine just seeing by the reuters news
agency within the last three moments
they've been speaking to an eu official
saying it's not clear yet if there will
be a meeting of eu leaders to respond to
the move by russia which the british
government has seen as an invasion of
ukraine if there is one they say it
would be held in person so we'll keep an
eye on what's going to happen as far as
that's concerned we certainly know that
the prime minister is holding a cobra
meeting as we speak we did see the
foreign secretary entering uh downing
street earlier today they convened that
meeting at half past six this morning we
are expecting to hear from the prime
minister once that has concluded so of
course we'll bring that to you just as
soon as we can meantime let's bring in
tobias elwood conservative mp and former
defence minister and also chair of the
defence select committee hello to you mr
elwood i know you've been to ukraine uh
very recently they were concerned about
what was going to happen next i had um
the health secretary on the program a
short time ago he was saying that as far
as the british government is concerned
this the invasion has now begun is that
how you see it
yes absolutely right the health
secretary is correct the prospect of war
in europe has moved a little closer as
putin gives the green light for that
massive military buildup that we've been
speaking about for some time to enter
the donbass region
and uh he's clearly this approach
breaches the minx agreements
specifically the normandy format this
was the vehicle that would be used to
facilitate any change for this region
that's now simply been ignored and quite
rightly this has been met by huge
international uh condemnation not least
from the british
with much discussions about fresh
sanctions my question is my concern is
will any sanctions actually alters
putin's uh thinkings or as in uh plans
to invade further uh into ukraine and
for that you've got to ask actually ask
the question what is putin's strategy
what's his long-term
objective uh he can't reform his country
because his economy is so poor so he
must rule by fear and he requires an
adversary so he distracts and blames the
woes at home he blames nato for that but
he's also seeking a legacy his country
is not rich oil and gas is his thing but
the west is not a guaranteed market and
i think there's a wider picture emerging
here of russia putin wanting to turn his
nation towards the east that's the new
geopolitical alliance that we have to uh
recognize if that is the case then it
does beg the questions as to when he any
sanctions that we impose might actually
play into his plan
how important is britain into what
happens
next i was looking at a quote from the
white house press secretary overnight
talking about the french president and
the german chancellor and the u.s
president all um speaking as one no
mention of the uk
oh it's important that the uk is
included we were one of the first
nations to offer our support providing
military training uh and equipment uh to
ukraine that was very evident when i
went out there as well historically
we've been one of the nations that steps
forward perhaps when others hesitate it
is important that the west works uh in
unity because that is exactly what putin
is exploiting and the two big questions
you have now for the west as we move
into this escalated new phase of this
crisis is firstly how do we effectively
respond uh to russia now it's breached
international law and secondly
the most important question i hope that
will be discussed today is how can we
further assist our ukrainian friends
like i say we were one of the first of
military aid but what more military
systems can we provide and is there
something that nato this most formidable
military alliance in the world
can be better utilized to act as a
deterrent such as for example the
implementation of a no-fly zone
okay um
do we also need to consider i i did put
this also to the health secretary
whether we move from defensive weaponry
to offensive weaponry in ukraine and he
said all of this is being considered in
cobra at the moment is that an option
it's not just an option it's a
requirement we need to recognize that we
have a duty to our ukrainian friends
nato needs to remind itself what it says
on the tin it is european security we
cannot park what happens in ukraine
outside of the nato family
and just watch what happens there will
be consequences already to european
economies because of uh the invasion oil
gas prices food prices are likely to
increase where does this go next that's
the big question that needs to be asked
if we don't come to the support of
ukraine
as far as
the president putin is concerned he says
his troops are on a peacekeeping
mission um and that
he
is there to support these two
breakaway regions of um ukraine and that
will be the point that he continues to
hammer home what would our response to
that be
well we must recognize that we don't uh
agree with those decrees that the duma
has passed that the putin spoke about
last night that donna lawrence and
donetsk are not part of separatist
states but actually part of ukraine
proper as indeed is crimea which we i'm
afraid failed to act responsibly um in
2014. this is our moment to make sure
that we stand up stand firmly to putin
recognize the wider geopolitical
movements that are taking place because
there will be huge consequences if we
allow this to run so let's utilize nato
to its full capacity let's consider uh
where putin wants to go long term let's
make sure we stand firm with our
ukrainian friends
um you've just come back haven't you
from ukraine what was it like what was
the mood like
very very tense indeed but a resilience
as well a determination to say that this
is their country and they will fight for
it and even if
russia moves its tanks all the way into
the capital to kiev that they will make
it so undigestable if you like so
miserable for any regime uh to actually
try and own it for any length of time
and that's why it's so important that we
look at the assistance that we can
provide militarily whether it be drones
the counter cyber capabilities uh other
weapon systems that can allow them to
operate not just taking on
russia conventionally but also to
operate an insurgency which no doubt
will follow if a full invasion doesn't
uh does occur
we're glad to see you safe back home mr
elwood thank you for joining us on the
program
thank you
just before we let you go if you're
heading off to work the weather much
better than it has been to be fair so
instead i just want to show you these
fun pictures let's take you to sicily uh
mount etna has begun erupting my
goodness me i think i'm writing saying
that it's the most active volcano in
europe am i right in saying that i'm
sure if i'm not somebody will tell me
very quickly on twitter um it's the
latest eruption in the region there have
been no reports of any injuries or
serious damage to property but
volcanologists say there has been a rise
in activity suggesting that aetna could
be headed towards an even more
violent outburst that is what's
happening i'm guessing aircraft that
normally fly over that area as a result
will be at making sure they stay away at
least
for now i wonder whatever happened to
that volcano that had been erupting for
weeks and weeks and weeks in the canary
islands
don't know
yeah i don't know we'll check it out for
you uh coming up the latest from ukraine
as sadie javid tells this program the
invasion of ukraine has already begun he
went on to say that it is a dark day for
europe as far as the prime minister is
concerned he is presently hosting a
cobra meeting in downing street we saw
the foreign secretary heading into
downing street um just before 6 30 this
morning we are hopeful that we'll be
able to hear from the prime minister in
this programme
to tell us what the next move is as far
as britain is concerned as far as the
government is concerned they say that
given what happened overnight they see
it as an invasion
of ukraine by russia what happens next
[Music]